BRIGITTE GOSSELINK:
All right everyone.
Well, welcome and thanks for
sticking with us through what
I know has been a
long, hopefully really
fun, days here at I/O.
I'm Brigitte Gosselink.
I'm part of the
team at Google.org.
And yesterday, so as Sundar
was closing the keynote-- so
be honest how many
people actually made it
that far through the keynote
and actually heard the closing?
OK, that's not bad.
Good job, team.
If you haven't, I think
it's worth watching,
as it's relevant to the content
that we have here today.
He talked about the power of
applying the most cutting edge
computing that we have to the
world's biggest challenges.
And at Google.org,
we fund and support
organizations who
are really working
to make that promise,
the promise of technology
to have social
impact, a reality.
And it was interesting for me
because yesterday's keynote
actually brought me a
little bit full circle
back to last year's keynote.
In last year's keynote
there was a video
that profiled a man from
Brazil named Carlos,
who is working on a piece
of assistive technology
for his daughter.
And the organizations that
we're working with here today
that are here to share
their work with you,
as well as many of
the organizations
we supported last
year, actually were all
working to tackle a specific
set of challenges facing people
with disabilities.
So first a quick poll.
How many people here
either identify themselves
as having a disability
or know someone who does?
It's a lot of people.
And in fact, as many
of you probably know,
one in seven people in the world
have some form of disability.
That's a billion people.
It's the world's
largest minority.
And we know that technology
has the potential
to help increase independence
and opportunity for people
with disabilities, for
that billion people.
Something very exciting
is happening outside.
GINNY GRANT: And here.
BRIGITTE GOSSELINK: And
here, which is great.
So last year at I/O, we
actually announced plans
to award $20 million in
funding, in Google.org funding
and support, for
nonprofit organizations
who are trying to
help push forward
independence and opportunity.
We launched an open call.
And we were really blown
away by the response we got.
We had more than 1,000
applications from 88 countries.
One of those applications
was from Carlos.
And Carlos actually proposed to
use natural language processing
and context-- a couple things
we heard a little bit about here
so far at I/O-- to improve
the assistive communication
software that he was building
so that his daughter could
communicate.
She has communication
limitations,
as someone with cerebral palsy.
And so for example,
he wanted the software
to be able to, in the
morning when she wakes up,
suggest on her picture
board breakfast items,
because it knows
that she's at home.
And she knows in the
morning she wants breakfast.
She shouldn't have
to navigate in
to find these
through several menus
options, so that she
can say that she wants oatmeal.
So it was really
exciting for me to hear
Sundar talking about the
promise of those practices.
And we're excited to be
funding Carlos to do that work.
And actually what
he'll be building
will all be open source, so
that other assistive devices
and software can hopefully
benefit from the same work
that he's using.
And I'm thrilled to have here
today four other organizations
who won funding through that
challenge, who are all working
on really hard problems.
If you want to check out any
of the other projects and ideas
that we funded,
they're all available.
You can check them out
at g.co/disabilities.
So with that, I will turn
it over to the panelists
to introduce themselves,
tell you a little bit more
about their work.
They'll talk about who they
are as people, technologists
working on social challenges.
Hopefully that's
interesting to some of you.
And what the problem
is that they're
working on, as well
as their approach
to trying to solve
that challenge.
Arnon, you want to start us off?
ARNON ZAMIR: Sure.
Hi everybody, very
excited to be here.
My name is Arnon Zamir.
I come from Tel Aviv, where I
run an organization named TOM.
That's T-O-M. Myself,
I'm a software
developer by profession and
by occupational history.
But in the last
three years or so,
I've been running social
technology involved projects.
The crown jewel of those is TOM.
What we do with TOM is
create an umbrella system
for technologies to be involved
in assisting and empowering
people with disabilities.
We're looking for
challenges that
can-- and therefore should--
be addressed by technology.
And we're looking for two
cases, two main cases.
Either where a solution for
a challenge does not exist,
or where a solution
exists, but it is not
affordable to many people,
due to either propriety
rights on the design or other
reasons, usually customization,
which makes products
very expensive.
We are looking for
technology makers that
are willing to put some time
into development of solutions,
and then people with
disabilities and experts, which
we call need knowers, those
that can describe the need.
And we facilitate the
meeting of the two.
We're creating very high end,
very complicated make-a-thons,
marathons of makers; and then
taking the products of those
into continuous
development products, which
we call developer groups.
And finally with the generous
assistance of Google.org,
we're able to create
a web platform that
helps all of those take
a path to market, again,
as a nonprofit organization
on an open source
version of everything that
we requires and develop.
That's the one liner.
A long line.
BRIGITTE GOSSELINK:
Great, Ginny?
GINNY GRANT: Hi,
I'm Ginny Grant.
I'm a senior product
manager at Benetech.
And in my history, I've been
a technologist for many years.
I was also a classroom
teacher and volunteer.
And when I came to Benetech
about 4 and 1/2 years ago,
I found my calling,
because Benetech
is a completely different
kind of technology company.
Like you, we look
for opportunities
where we can serve communities
that otherwise are not
as well served, whether it's
in an environmental sense.
We have tools which allow
conservationists to report
issues with their ecosystem.
We also have secure tools that
our human rights advocates are
able to use to
report human rights
violations around the world.
And then in the group
that I'm most focused on,
our global literacy team, we
serve over 400,000 members
who are able to get our
books in an accessible
format for their
needs, whether it's
because they have
a vision impairment
or they've lost
the use of a limb.
Perhaps whether
it's cerebal palsy,
or they've served their
country and have lost an arm,
had a stroke, or they also
have a learning difference,
a disability such as dyslexia
that causes the words not
to form properly
unless they're served
in multimodal, both visual and
auditorily, and highlighted.
So it's really
exciting that we're
able to bring those
kind of technologies
to people around the world.
And I'll be talking more
later about the details
of how we're doing that.
BRIGITTE GOSSELINK:
Go ahead, Holger.
HOLGER DIETERICH: Hello,
my name is Holger.
I am the co-founder
of wheelmap.org.
My background is in-- I have
a degree in design and work
in product management a lot.
The problem I found with
my best friend, Raul,
who was using
electric wheelchair,
is where can we actually
hang out and have a coffee,
go to a bar, mundane things?
And we think that inclusion
means that everybody should
take part in daily life
equally, no matter if they
have a disability or not.
So what I figured out
was why do we always
go to the cafe in your area?
Why don't you come
to my neighborhood?
So we're from Berlin, Germany.
And we have lots
of old buildings.
And what I didn't know before
is that a lot of these buildings
have steps in the entrance so
you cannot get in when you have
an electric wheelchair.
So he said, you know,
I don't know where
I can get in your neighborhood.
Like yeah, but you cannot be the
only wheelchair user in Berlin
or in this neighborhood.
So what about building
an app where everybody
can look around and mark
places, physical places
like restaurants, cafes,
anything, any public places
and say yes, they are
wheelchair accessible or no,
they are not
wheelchair accessible.
So we built that five years ago.
And it's now the
largest data set
in the world with more
than 650,000 marked places.
And we're online
in 22 languages.
So what we do know
now is that we
want to bring this to
other location based
services and maps apps,
so that they can augment
their service with wheelchair
accessibility, but not only
our sources, but from
other nonprofits,
from other data sources as well.
So that's for me.
BRIGITTE GOSSELINK:
Go ahead, Ume.
UMESH PANDYA: Hi all.
I'm Ume, or my full
name is Umesh Pandya.
I have been a
designer for 15 years.
And we work out of London.
And I look after an
organization called Wayfindr.
And Wayfindr's
mission is to empower
vision impaired people
to independently navigate
the world.
And that's our sole existence.
That's what we do
day in, day out.
Now what we do will be
quite specific here,
is that we do not create an app.
We're creating an open standard
for audio based way finding.
And what that
allows people to do
is it allows venue owners,
such as transport networks,
and retailers, and
navigation app developers,
to have a common
language together.
So they can look at the
standard and understand
how they might make their
space accessible for indoor
navigation for blind people.
Now, currently we're using BLE.
So we're using Bluetooth
beacons to allow turn
by turn navigation.
An example of that
is some installations
that we've done in London.
And we've done some
installations over in Sydney.
And that tells the user
walk straight or turn right
or go down an escalator.
And all of these
instructions and guidelines
are baked into the guidelines
that we published last week,
in the open standard.
BRIGITTE GOSSELINK: Perfect.
Well thanks so much for
those overviews, all.
I think I'd like to
start with a discussion
about inclusive
design in general.
And in specific, how we can
think about technology really
being part of the answer
for some of the challenges
that face people
with disabilities.
And obviously, that's the
core of what you all do.
But I thought it would be
useful for this audience
to perhaps give a little
bit more of the advice
that you would have, for
really designing with this user
population in mind.
Ginny, do you want
to start us off?
GINNY GRANT: All right.
So a number of things.
The first thing
off is start early.
Think about accessibility
as soon as you can.
Write with usability.
You never want to
bake it back in later.
You can't change
the ingredients.
It's so much better
to start upfront.
So look for all the
design standards.
And I know other
people are going
be talking about this too,
but thinking about the-- POUR
I believe is a good acronym.
The P-O-U-R. So go look that up.
Google that.
But making sure that every
illustration or image that's
on your web page or in your
tool is accessible to all.
Turn off the volume.
Turn down the monitor.
Or even try to use an oven
mitt to try to navigate.
If you had to use a
switch, and you just
needed to be able
to move around,
you can't assume that people
have all the dexterity
that some others do.
So work that in from
the very get go.
There's a lot of other things.
But also work through standards.
Ume, you mentioned that earlier.
Try to improve the standard
so that more people
can spread that capability of
technology that is accessible.
I think that's a
good starting point.
BRIGITTE GOSSELINK:
Yeah, definitely.
Arnon, do you want
to add anything?
ARNON ZAMIR: I'd like
to tap into that.
And that's a very
important part of creating
anything inclusive and
anything accessible
is being in a constant dialogue
with the people that need it.
One of the principles,
which is articulated
in the saying from Holger,
"nothing about us without us."
Don't do anything for someone.
Always do with someone.
When we work at TOM, we define
our goal and our methodology
as facilitating the meeting
points of challenge and talent.
We bring people that can
donate some of their time,
and we sit them in the same
room and the same table
with the people that can
understand the challenge.
So imagine that you were
developing a productivity
app for young mothers.
First thing you would have
done is go meet young mothers
and analyze their
productivity challenges.
That's obvious for every
development team working
on designing their new app.
The same thing is true with
anything from wheelchair
accessibility, to
visual impairment aids,
to applications for
people with disabilities.
Just have your client,
the need knower, with you.
And another small angle on
that is that accessibility
is one thing.
Design your application to
be accessible for people
with certain limitations.
Another angle can be when you're
meeting with a new technology,
or when you're creating
a new technology, one
of the things we found
out, some people right away
think, what can
this technology do
for people with disabilities?
So if we have a new
visual design theme,
or if we have a
contextual engine,
or if we have anything new
happening in the big technology
world, right away we
think, how can this
be put in use for people
with disabilities.
There is no
advancement today that
is not tied with technology,
and this is not an exception.
BRIGITTE GOSSELINK: Right.
Really building in
as a use case and not
as an add-on or
something that you
might need a whole different
piece of software for,
a different device.
I think that really speaks
to that inclusive nature.
I think for people who maybe
feel uncertain about how
to get close to those
user needs, which I think
can sometimes feel
like a barrier
when you're trying to develop
solutions in this space, what
advice would you all have for
the best way to get close,
get proximate to those needs?
Holger, did you want to take it?
HOLGER DIETERICH: Me, or you?
You want to start?
UMESH PANDYA: I can go.
With the way that
we do it, day in,
day out is we use a methodology
called build, measure, learn.
And we also use user centered
design in everything we do.
So for example, in some of
the stations that we've done,
we've worked with
users over three weeks.
So every station we've
done, every installation
we've done, 25 users.
We bring them in.
We test with them one to one.
We iterate.
That means that we get five
iterations of our products
in one day.
That's pretty amazing.
Over the course of
three weeks, we've
got something that's validated.
All of that information gets
pushed up into standard.
And then we have an
awesome backlog of stuff
that we need to attack in our
next round of user testing.
So having users at the
center is really useful.
Prototyping is a really good way
to manage uncertainty as well.
So if you're
developing something,
and you're kind of unsure--
am I doing the right thing?
Or should I be
doing it this way?
Just get the users in the room.
Try and hunt out
the actual people
that have the needs that
you can help support.
If you can't get access to
them, try and find experts
that can help with that.
And then just work with them.
And the core thing is just
bake them into your process
and bake them into your
organization and how you do it.
You can't do it at a distance.
It's really difficult.
You have to have them
with you at all times.
BRIGITTE GOSSELINK: Yeah, I
mean I think Holger's story
with founding the organization
that he founded with Raul
is obviously the most
visceral way that you
can imagine doing that.
Just hire someone and
have them on your staff.
But if you can't do that,
I think some of the things
that you suggested,
Ume, are quite useful.
We also mentioned this
idea of experimentation.
And this is actually,
beyond this space, something
that I think is interesting
in the social impact
sector in general.
So we actually
don't think a lot,
in the same way that
we talk about launching
an iterate in Google and in
many of the technology that we
build.
We don't think as much
about it, I think,
sometimes when it comes
to social challenges.
And that's because
there are some,
I think, real barriers to that.
It's something that we
really encourage in the work
that we support and fund.
And a lot of the groups
that are represented here
are trying to do that.
I wonder if you all could
just give some reflections
on some of the difficulties
and barriers to doing
that well, given that you're
trying to, with your work,
also have great social impact.
HOLGER DIETERICH: Maybe
I can give an example.
So there were other
nonprofit organizations
who tried to do what
we did, for finding
wheelchair accessible places.
And they're experts in their
needs, as we said before.
But they're not experts
in building Android apps,
for example, or web
apps or making it scale.
So our data set is based
on open street map.
So you have to know this access.
You have to be able
to access the APIs
and to build around
it, make it stable,
maybe interact with others
and have a good design.
So I think where
things come together
is also to learn
from each other,
so that you as an expert
in software development
have a beginners
mindset in learning
about people with
disabilities and vice versa.
So I think there's
always something people
can help each other with.
BRIGITTE GOSSELINK:
Yeah, Ume, did
you have anything to add there?
UMESH PANDYA: What we've
learned along the journey--
because we're a joint venture
between a digital product
studio and a charity.
So it's a joint venture between
us two and the Royal London
Society for Blind People.
We're finding we're
learning both ways.
So to Holger's point, we're
bringing digital product,
design process and all that in.
But what the RLSB are
helping us understand
is the user and
the social impact.
So when we talk about measure
in build, measure, learn,
it gets expanded a little bit.
So when you talk about
measure in the design context,
we can measure usability,
whether the instructions are
correct, how many
people are using it,
regular stuff like that.
However if you're talking about
measurement in a social impact
space, is that
how do you measure
how someone felt
before they used
the Wayfindr-enabled system?
How do they feel after it?
Have we moved them along that
journey to a better well-being?
These are interesting
challenges that take us out
of the product space and more
into a social impact space.
And these are
exciting times for us,
when we start to
unpack these things.
BRIGITTE GOSSELINK: I don't
know if people on Livestream
can hear the cheering that's
happening outside this tent.
But this is apparently a
very popular discussion.
Getting a lot of
support right now.
GINNY GRANT: I'd
love to add another--
BRIGITTE GOSSELINK: I
was going to say, Ginny,
I think that you all have
some great experience
for this idea of iterating.
GINNY GRANT: Well, so Bookshare
and Benetech have been around
actually for about 12
years, before the Kindle
and those other
electronic books,
when we first started to
make books available online.
And our whole mantra
was about making
books accessible in the
digital format that they need
and people can get
it through the web.
And then we've been
starting-- especially
as we've been expanding out
to other countries and places
that aren't as
economically affluent.
And it's been fascinating to
see old technology that still
has IE6 embedded right in it.
And how do we work with that?
Or places that--
well now they're
actually putting their
library books on CDs
and sending them out through
the postal service every month
to their patrons.
And we're trying to change,
socially, the cultural as well
as technology.
So we're definitely
hitting constraints
where people who may not be
as economically advantaged
can't switch out technology
as fast as we here,
especially in this
wonderful Silicon Valley,
think it can happen.
But we're trying to make
those strides to get people
to that point-- again,
working with and not for.
So that's been an
interesting challenge.
BRIGITTE GOSSELINK: What
are some of the strategies
that you've taken to
try to deal with that?
Obviously some of it is
updating your software
to work all the way back IE6.
So congratulations to you.
GINNY GRANT: Well and on
that note, we actually,
last November, had to finally
cut the umbilical cord there.
BRIGITTE GOSSELINK: I think
they're now at 8, though.
ARNON ZAMIR: I'm sorry.
GINNY GRANT: So they're
out of the nest now.
But they have other
ways of doing it.
Unfortunately there
were some people
who were still so accustomed.
And some of it is
comfort levels,
because people have
become accustomed to doing
things the way they've
been doing things.
And so it's been an interesting
journey to work with people.
And again, baby steps of getting
people to try something out,
feel comfortable.
I love the idea of not
just looking at metrics
from a purely
objective perspective,
but that subjective
nature as well.
It's really cool.
So I guess that's some of
it is that we're also--
we work with open
source as well so
that we want to make sure that
other people can use pieces
that we build out.
The math-- we have
a MathML cloud
that we're evolving
that people will
be able to help
expand and then use
the MathML that's there in that
repository to reference that.
BRIGITTE GOSSELINK:
What's MathML, Ginny?
GINNY GRANT: Sorry
BRIGITTE GOSSELINK:
What is MathML?
GINNY GRANT: Oh
MathML, so sorry.
So imagine that you're
looking at a textbook that
has a cool equation
that's all laid out there.
And as a visual user,
you can see that.
But what if you can't see it?
You hav to hear
it, and so if it's
spoken out in a
markup language that
can be translated and voiced.
ChemML, chemistry, has
the same kind of concept.
And so being able to refer
to those different image
descriptor ways that
you can describe what,
to a visual person,
is just an image
makes it accessible to all.
Thank you.
BRIGITTE GOSSELINK: So you
touched on something there
that I guess I touched
on as well in my intro,
in talking about what
Carlos is doing, which
is this idea of open source.
And one of the things that we
really promote as Google.org
is the idea of openness.
And it's not just for
the principle of it,
but also because
it's really critical
to see some of these
solutions come to scale.
So when we think about
the size of the problems
that people are working on,
that these organizations
and others are
working on, we also
have to think about
how could we imagine
one organization solving this.
And frankly, you can't.
So actually all of these
organizations-- and most
of those that we
support-- are actually
working to have
people actively adopt
what it is that
they're doing outside
of the walls of their
organization, which
in many ways is very different
than how we think, I think,
about a for profit enterprise.
In some ways, there's a
wall built up in order
to protect that.
And you ideally don't
see a lot of copycats.
Obviously, it cuts
into your revenue.
This is a flipped model with
what we're working with.
I would love you all
to just maybe explore
some of the challenges of that.
Obviously there are challenges.
I know that.
If you just say there aren't,
we've talked about them.
And also some of
what you've seen
to be successful in trying
to drive that adoption
beyond your own walls.
Why don't you start off, Arnon.
ARNON ZAMIR: I'll
be happy to share,
because that's a huge
part of what we're doing.
So imagine that you're
building a product.
And then it's
relatively successful.
You want it to grow up.
And you want to scale it up.
And now imagine that
your goal in this
is not to sell it for
that, but to actually
transform a situation,
to move the needle.
In our case, our goal is to
move the needle in accessibility
to assistive technology.
So we want that
everywhere in the world.
Assistive technology, whatever
that is for your needs
will be available for
you, regardless of
how much money you
have or where you are.
Obviously, being a team
of seven people now--
three people until recently--
we cannot do that alone.
So from the ground up,
the whole mechanism
behind our work at TOM
is community engagement.
We actively work to transfer
ownership from our own team
to the teams that are
working on specific projects.
So if we have, for example, a
tablet-based accessibility app,
we don't want to
direct the team.
We don't want to
own the product.
We just want to support
them as they own
the process and the results.
And this is true with
3D-printed prosthetic arms
that we are doing-- sometimes
based on open source assisting
models-- or with
wheelchair adjustments,
or everything else.
And then we actively incorporate
into our system mechanisms
for replication.
We are building
a website that is
going to be an eBay-style
experience, a marketplace
experience for people to
actively go online and download
our material and copy
it and transform it.
And we are heavily
encouraging teams to do this.
One of our challenges
is, on the one hand,
how do we get as many groups
in the world as possible
to take our products, transform
them to their local needs
and implement them.
On the other hand, make
sure that no one is doing
something unwanted with it.
What would something
unwanted be?
Use it for something that
we consider immoral or just
irresponsible or using--
BRIGITTE GOSSELINK:
Commercializing and going
against your affordability
principles, for example.
ARNON ZAMIR: So commercializing
is an interesting aspect
because we are not
against commercializing,
as long as you keep the
open source files available.
So some commercialization
models can
work as open source products.
Some of you might
know-- do you know
WordPress and a semi-famous
operation system
called Android?
You might have heard of.
They're all based on
open source projects
or they are open
source projects.
And they are
relatively profitable.
So that's not necessarily
a contradiction.
But then again, if someone
tries to close what we're doing
and not share it
with the world all,
we'll have a problem with that.
Organization-wise, we had
a couple of months ago,
we had the team in
Canada-- very strong,
very enthusiastic
about TOM's work--
running around, running a
make-a-thon of their own,
working now on the
second one and building
a ground up operation
in a city called Calgary
on the West Coast of Canada.
And they went ahead
and registered
an organization named
Tikkum Olam Makers, which
is TOM, T-O-M. That's our name.
And we said, OK,
how do we do that?
And in case, Richard, you're
watching the video, hi.
One approach, the
commercial approach,
would be this is our name.
You're not going to
do anything with that.
We are going to
protect ourselves
against this infringement.
But then we want the
community to grow.
So it's a constant debate, a
constant dialogue with them,
understanding the limits.
And remember that
we are very young.
We've been doing this
for about two years.
And there's no
other organization
to look and learn
from, almost none.
So it's a constant balancing
and pushing back and forward
process.
Right now, very challenging
but very satisfying,
and we're seeing growth.
HOLGER DIETERICH:
Actually also what
we learned is that I have
lot of friends in Berlin
who are working in
startups and saying,
what's the business
model behind WheelMap?
Would you put advertising on it?
Or do you have an API and sell
by the 1,000 maps you serve
or something like that?
But we really made
the hard decision.
We are a nonprofit organization.
So we will never
be millionaires.
We are out there
to save the world.
So what we want to
maximize is impact.
So the more people that
use it, the better.
If I put a price tag on
this, it will hinder my goal.
And we will potentially
not reach as many people.
So our apps are free.
We want to encourage that
data is open and free.
At least it's available in
an understandable format
so that people can understand
where to find this,
because once you decide
that's your goal,
you should put all
the effort into that.
And what we learned
along the way,
working also with organizations
like Google and other
commercial organizations
is that they appreciate
what we do and want to help.
And they help us do
this along the way.
So for example,
we're doing a project
with a German railway system,
so the railway corporation.
It's an organization
with 300,000 employees.
And what we're
interested in is you
don't want to get stuck
at a train station
because the elevator
is not working.
So you need real
time information on
is an elevator working
or not, on a lift.
So we built a project
to highlight that.
But there wasn't a good
realtime API from them.
So we built
something on scraping
and we're stealing
actually from their website
to show that demo
that what we could do.
And instead of hating us
they said, hey, let's talk.
How can we make this happen?
We don't really understand.
And now they have a full-fledged
open data initiative
to make this happen.
And now they have
a realtime API,
which can be included in all
travel planning around Germany.
And that's our goal.
So and actually now
we're consulting them.
And they pay us for this.
And that's maybe how
good things can happen.
And we maximize our impact.
So if we would
charge for that, we
wouldn't have this
liaison, this relationship
in the first place.
So it's very different
from-- well, in one area,
it's also we must
not go bankrupt.
Otherwise we cannot
save the world.
But otherwise, we need
to trust in our cause.
UMESH PANDYA: I'd like to
iterate on both your points is
that we believe that
adoption of the standard
directly equals to
the social impact.
And we know that,
as an organization,
we can't do it all.
We need to bring together
transport networks,
or built-environment owners.
We need to bring together
charities and vision impaired
people to organizations that
look after vision impaired
people.
We need to bring together
the software and the hardware
guys that work in the
indoor navigation space.
We need to bring
in the researchers
and the universities that
are dealing with this.
And so we've created
the Wayfindr community,
where we've got a good amount
of members in there now.
And we're scaling
that up, because we
have now the second part of
our standard development--
which we released last week--
is to now work together
with these organizations to
develop the standard together.
So our potential clients
or the potential people
that will increase
the adoption are also
baked into the process
of creating our product.
So not only our users
are part of our process,
our customers are also
part of our process
to send out and
develop our product.
So we know that we're making
something that's actually
usable and somebody needs,
rather than something
that's a pure guess.
And that's why it's
quite important
to have these people really
close and work alongside you
in a collaborative manner.
BRIGITTE GOSSELINK: So I
feel like you guys are making
it sound really easy to save
the world, which is great,
because we would love to have
more people working on this.
But I know it's
also pretty hard,
and that you all had
a bunch of challenges
that you're experiencing
all the time.
And I think some of
these are parts of those.
But I would love to just hear
a couple of stories about some
of the hard part of
this, what's been
a really challenging problem
that you've encountered,
and how you've
worked through that,
or the craziest day
at work that you had,
or something like that.
Yeah, go ahead.
Or go ahead Ginny.
GINNY GRANT: I could do one.
I mean, there's many
crazy days at work.
But that's why we all do it.
We love it.
When Bookshare started,
there was obviously
a concern or almost a threat
felt by the publishing industry
that we were somehow stealing
the intellectual property, very
much in the sense of music,
if you think about some
of the shared music services
that there were for a while.
But Benetech is very, very clear
on digital rights management
and policies.
And so we've had to really step
up our game there and prove
that we're not trying to
share intellectual property.
It's very important.
But then the other thing
we've done is, to your point,
we've really worked with
the publishing industry
to produce standards that
they will then, in turn,
start to build out
all of the books
and magazines and literature
with these standards that
will enable everybody
to be able to use them.
Accessible, born accessible,
and accessible for all.
So I think it was a huge
challenge at the beginning.
And we now have
publishers coming to us
saying, how can we
get into your group?
And in fact, teach us
how to make the books
that we make more accessible.
So that has been a huge
switch, again, needle moving.
BRIGITTE GOSSELINK:
Do you want to add?
UMESH PANDYA: I mean, we
move daily between granular
to a high level.
And what I mean by that is how
we develop the product, what
the process is, what the
upgrades we're going to do,
to the bigger level
which is how we're
going to change
policy in London,
especially right around the--
BRIGITTE GOSSELINK: Just you,
you're gonna do it yourself.
UMESH PANDYA: So how do we deal
with that when you're flipping
between these two things?
And it's really hard.
Because when you're used to
making digital products, which
you can just evolve overnight
or every hour, and then
you're working with a system
that changes over years,
how do you ensure
that you're going
to be still alive to see
the fruits of your labor,
and then see whether it's
actually delivered an impact?
So these are the kind of
things that bounce around
in our minds,
which are like, OK,
are we using our
time efficiently?
And where do we
push our efforts?
Before when we would work
for clients and do products,
it's like, here we're going
to push these pixels around
and make it really
nice, and dah, dah, dah.
But when it becomes more
about delivering this change,
it's all about
actually, you know what?
Some of that can stay there.
Don't worry about that.
We need to deliver this, because
this is the impact that it's
going to directly deliver.
So it's kind of a flip,
been quite a flip for us.
HOLGER DIETERICH:
So one small thing
I can tell you-- maybe US app
developers can relate to-- is
that it's like being
a charity is not
an excuse for bad quality.
So we, for example, we
didn't have a lot of testing.
And we were learning
it along the way.
And in the beginning, when
you didn't allow location,
and you opened the app, you were
getting weird error messages.
Something's not working, and
you have to click it five times
to get rid of it.
And then maybe you
don't even have
point of interest or
something like that.
So we didn't notice that
somebody would do this
because we didn't think of it.
And we're stupid, maybe.
But we immediately got one
star reviews on the app store
for a free app run by a
charity on donors' money.
And we were like, what?
We're putting our
heart into this.
And you're still like,
immediately one star, one star,
one star.
But actually it's also good,
because it proves the point
that they deserve good quality,
and that we must deliver this
as well.
And we're just
considered another app.
It's actually an achievement
that is not like,
it's kind of crappy.
But it's charity.
Well, it's not anymore.
It has to be well-designed.
And it has to work.
And we worked a long
time on doing this.
And I'm proud that the
apps are working now.
And you don't have to have
location enabled all the time.
BRIGITTE GOSSELINK:
I think we sometimes
have this myth a little bit
that either products that
are done through nonprofits
can be fine but not great.
Or that doing this type of work
is actually easier than harder.
I think sometimes it's both.
It's fun.
And you get inspired by it.
But it's also a lot
of hard challenges.
I would love for you all, who
have made this move from being
technologists in maybe a
more mainstream environment,
to doing things that are really
using those technical skills
for good, inspire
some people out here
to do the same who are
listening to you all speak.
Arnon, this is what
you do every day,
so maybe I'll turn
it to you to start.
ARNON ZAMIR: First of all, yes,
this is what we do every day.
We have a very simple
strategic approach,
which is do and do now.
We're very open
for technologists
and half-technologists,
and sometimes
non-technologists to join us
and participate in a development
of some feature in a product.
And as a person
reaches-- partially
our inspiration John
Shull from e-NABLE says,
a prosthetic arm
that is 3D printed
needs to just be diminishingly
better than nothing.
And we are very good that
bringing together people
to develop solutions that
are diminishingly better
than nothing and then very,
very better than nothing.
And you're all invited to
join, because you don't
need to change everything.
We're not asking people
to stop what they're doing
and start doing just
work for society.
We're asking people to donate
either three days in the year,
or three hours in the week.
And we have a non-written
agreement with them.
You give us your time.
And we'll make sure it's
dedicated to something very
good, which is many times
going to sustain and move
forward and grow and
change somebody's life.
And the world is full with
opportunities to do good things
and to marvel in them.
And I'm very happy to engage
everyone online and offline
in our activity.
I want to tell a very
short story about a product
that you can see
in a booth here.
BRIGITTE GOSSELINK: It's in
the Access and Empathy Sandbox,
if you haven't made it by.
ARNON ZAMIR: That booth.
There's a product
called The Grabber.
It looks like a pair of clamps,
with a mouth operated thingy
at the end.
It was created
with a friend named
Kim from Northern California.
She was born, unfortunately,
with no limbs.
And she had some
difficulties reaching
things that are far from
her side, from her reach
by her mouth.
And it was created exactly to
her measurements, to her need,
and relatively successful.
About a week ago, I got this
video of a Whatsapp showing
the same instrument
transferred into something new,
kind of forked like a open
source software can be forked.
The guys took it.
And on the clamps, they
put the hands of a doll
and the head of a doll
and two bells at the end.
And now it is a
clapping doll that
is used for a parent, which is
disabled from the neck down,
to play with his
four-year-old daughter.
He's holding it.
And he can clap the hands,
which he couldn't before.
Exactly the same mechanism,
different interpretation.
We could never have gotten
to this without open source
accessibility and without
the community being so daring
and doing stuff we're
never thinking of.
So join us.
BRIGITTE GOSSELINK: Ginny,
what advice would you have?
And what's one thing that people
can do walking out of here?
GINNY GRANT: Well,
besides making sure
that anything you build can be
used with a single oven mitt,
or turn off your
monitor and your volume
to make sure that
anyone and everyone can
use whatever you're
building, which
is going to be great quality.
Of course, there's always
applying to Benetech.
We have multiple
jobs open that would
do all kinds of great things.
But I would say definitely
build out your ecosystem.
Get to know people
who care about this.
And demand accessibility
everywhere.
HOLGER DIETERICH: I
think what we learned
is that we can-- if you want
to do something and support
a nonprofit
organization like ours
or like the others,
empathy is fine.
But what we do need
is your expertise.
One idea is in the beginning,
we had on our website,
you want to become a hero?
Help us, something like that.
Contact us.
So we got random people
wanting to volunteer.
We changed this completely.
We said, we need a
JavaScript fronted expert
in design, three months, unpaid,
one day per week-- something
like that-- for a nonprofit
organization as volunteer work.
So we were blunt and
upfront about this.
And we actually got
something like applications
from really cool
people we hired later.
Because it was sometimes
the first moment when
they could say, hey I can
play with this cool framework
for the first time and
actually have an impact.
One story is that
the first Android
app was built by our users
who were hating that we only
were on iOS.
And we said like, well, we don't
have the means to pay somebody
to do this.
And we said, but I can
bring you together.
And actually three
people came together
to build this remotely.
And one actually
quit his day job
and became a freelance
Android developer afterwards,
because he had this reference
of a successful world app
with a worldwide impact.
We completely
trusted this person
because there was nothing.
What can go wrong?
We have a back end.
We have an API.
Cool things can be
built. And I think this
is where it should come from.
I'm interested in this framework
and this new technology.
I always wanted to
try this and that out.
So there are places
where you can Google,
where you can search for
charities or things you
can help by the programming
language you prefer,
for example.
We, for example, we have on
GitHub all our source code.
And we have issues which have
the tag easy and mentored
so that we can bring new
contributors on board
and not just say, hey,
check out the whole thing.
And you will figure it out.
That's not how it works.
Start with something easy.
And if it's fun, do more.
As you contribute and submit
a pull request, and then we
will look at it and merge it.
And maybe you do more.
So think of what you would like
to work, what's fun for you.
And then, I think,
this collaboration
will work really well.
UMESH PANDYA: I'll
keep it short.
I think it's going to
be quite immediate.
I'm assuming that most
of you are developers.
I've done this before.
It might get you fired or
it might not get you fired.
You're the guys that
actually implement the code.
Now implementing accessibility
into it is not a hard effort.
So start rogue.
Your client gives you a project.
Just start implementing
it in there.
It's not hard.
We've done it before.
Now then you can then
go back to your client
and say, look, actually,
like 70% of your app
is now accessible.
Do you want to make the
rest of it accessible?
I've seen that work
many times before.
So I'd recommend you go
and do that immediately.
From a Wayfindr point of
view, we are an open standard.
So we want you guys to
come along and if you can,
contribute towards it.
If you can, share.
And we would love your feedback.
And this is how we want to grow.
So hit us up at
wayfindr.net/standard--
that's wayfinder without
the E. And we'd love to hear
your feedback.
BRIGITTE GOSSELINK: Perfect.
Well, one of my
favorite parts of my job
is that I have the privilege
to meet passionate people who
are working to use
technology for social good.
So I'm glad to have been able
to share that privilege a little
bit with you all today.
Please join me in
thanking our panelists.
And let's go hang out with
the fun people outside.
[APPLAUSE]